but now I know is this you turn upstairs
you've got a little bit of hot sauce on
your finger and then yeah you can play
Greek tragedy
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Kate Blanchett
she's one of the most decorating
accomplished actors of Our Generation
with a resume that includes more than 70
films and 20 plus theater Productions
along with countless Awards including
multiple Oscars her latest project
though is the Todd field written and
directed psychological drama tar which
opens in Select theaters beginning
October 7th with a wider release
scheduled for later this month on
October 28th Kate Blanchette welcome to
the show thank you before we get started
how are you around spicy food and what's
going through your mind as we prepare to
take down the hot ones challenge I'm
really scared but I guess it's probably
the closest you'll ever get to knowing
what menopause feels like so yeah so
I've been through it so I'm I don't and
spicy food I love but um I'm look I'm
really sweating already I'm getting
anticipatory anxiety okay layer one gone
the layers are coming off that means
we're ready to go
oh
foreign
[Music]
that's my doctor
okay ready
that's manageable mm-hmm
that's nice
so in your latest movie tar you play a
world famous composer whose life begins
to unravel as they approach a career
Milestone what was the experience like
presiding over the actual Dresden
Philharmonic for the scene featuring
Mueller's fifth I've heard you describe
an electric charge that went through you
at the raised Podium yeah do you do you
play an instrument no I don't the spoons
just the uh hot sauce
yeah well it was absolutely terrifying I
mean I played the piano as a as a girl
so I kind of I sort of understood an
instrument that way but you know a
conductor's instrument is the orchestra
and so the weirdest thing is and I don't
know why it seems so obvious that you
prepare in silence because you have the
score in front of you and you imagine
the music in your head and Miles five if
you know for those of you who haven't
listened you must Listen to It's a
massive massive exciting work and when
he gave the downbeat the trumpet started
and then that trial Marsh opened up it
was like an electric charge because
that's your instrument and you hear the
sound that you'd kind of Imagine but
when you have an orchestra like that
it's just um it was better than I
imagined it it was really addictive
actually
foreign
[Music]
has anyone ever thrown up oh um not on
the set
okay why do you feel like you might not
yet not yet all right just keep it up
so I'm intrigued by this quote of yours
For an upcoming role that you have in
Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio where you
play an animated monkey and said I'd
listen to a lot of different chimpanzees
then try everything out how does finding
the right tone for an animated monkey
how if at all does it compare to
mastering a regional dialect or the main
accents you've taken on throughout your
career from from which
um Forest did I choose the actual
chimpanzee it was kind of a melange of a
lot of different chimps but if you
listen to a lot of chimps they do sound
very different depending on their age
and um and then you just get in there
and work out what makes Guillermo laugh
and and yeah that's what I did
[Music]
so that was it was a bit like I had to
do a bit of Opera warm-up yeah you know
to get stress test stress test yeah so
that was it wasn't tedious but it was
taxing
because you know you get into the booth
and it's like hour after hour
[Music]
okay Pico Pico Pico Rico even
this looks like a um a fine wine yeah
got a chili oil in this one have you
ever drunk a whole bottle of it a whole
bottle of how far do you go like have
you have a hot sauce have you ever
jumped a whole bottle of no but you know
what I did do is I ate a Carolina Reaper
which is the hottest pepper in the world
so just like taking the pepper and just
eating it straight I did that one time
and that's probably more extreme than
like chugging a bottle and what happened
it just felt like I had food poisoning
for like a whole evening and then you
did it again I did it again and then I
did it again when you did that I was
always a young man 28 you know when did
you start doing this when did you
realize that this was your gift oh well
thanks for putting it that way it's I
almost think of it it's like the cross
that I bear at this point you know right
but um it wasn't a huge hit at first but
then we had this moment where it kind of
like broke through in this Mass
Discovery sort of way yeah yeah and I
remember at the time I was talking to
Chris who I started the show with hi
Chris hey Chris you know I I see that
you're over there and you're not up here
yeah he likes to hide in the shadows
you know he doesn't want to answer for
any of this but I was joking with him
like I'm eating a lot of hot food nobody
cares and then we had this moment where
it kind of broke through with a key and
peel episode that kind of went like
crazy viral and then the whole catalog
kind of lifted with it and then we were
kind of Off to the Races from there and
then here we are season 19 with you and
the season I can't believe it
was anyone ever just stopped right at
the beginning
it's crazy we've done like 300 episodes
of this and maybe only like 15 or 16
people have stopped before the end which
is no pressure no I'm not trying to lead
the witness or put any pressure on you
about that
when we had Elijah Wood on the show he
gave us a crash course and force
perspective what was the piece of
cinematic Wizardry that blew your mind
the most when you saw it in action on
set of Lord of the Rings I think it was
what what Peter Jackson was called and
I'm sure they're being used a lot now is
a split frame diopter it's something
they do with the lens so that you can
hold two people of monumentally
different sizes in the same frame and
that they would build a table where on
one side everything was obviously it was
a bit like um you know um a piece of
theater is that everything was large on
one side and everything was small on the
other side but there was something to do
with the lens where they were able to
hold them a bit like a kind of a fun
house mirror which was really incredible
because it was done in camera which was
pretty cool because a lot of that stuff
and I think you can feel it when it's
all done in post you know it's I love it
when those tricks are done in camera
[Music]
okay this is the this one looks really
scary
[Music]
I like that one
Mitchell do you cook not often but you
should see me order off a menu I'm great
I'd ordered that one that's great yeah
it's quote of yours theater is all about
foyers and conversation and digesting
what you've seen what's the role of the
theater itself and how audience receive
and digest plays and then out of
curiosity is there a theater that stands
out in your memory is just having like
the best foyer
one of my first jobs was in a I mean in
Australia a lot of the theaters are
found spaces so one was in a tomato
sauce factory and um uh and another one
was in a stable and so the the I the
actual dressing room was as literally as
big as these two tables put together and
I was in a cast of 12 and so it was
pretty tight and the downstairs was I
mean you literally kind of had to climb
a ladder to get up to the theater and
that was great the old stable was pretty
cool
what did you learn from being on the
other side of the audition table during
your time running the Sydney Theater
Company well actually you know when I
first came into drama school people
didn't know what to to do with me I sort
of didn't fit into any kind of box and a
costume director in Sydney took pity on
me and she would call me in to read
opposite people and that was such an
education because you could tell when as
soon as people walked in and go
you're not gonna get the job like as
soon as they walked in the door and and
you could tell the people who had a
fighting chance and I and so reading
opposite them was was kind of incredible
but then when we were my husband who's
here who's not eating hot sauce today
um but here for support yeah here for
support yeah yeah he's gonna hold my
hair back as I throw up into the bin
um but it was amazing to be on the other
side of of the of the dressing room door
to the theater you know when you're
directing a play or winning a produced a
show the actors go out and I felt a
profound relief that I didn't have to go
out there and then in talking about your
relationship to doing film roles versus
theater I've heard you say that you're
filled with regret on the last day of a
movie Shoot because it's then when you
really start to understand the character
yeah and all the things you Coulda
Shoulda would have done is there a movie
role of yours that you most wish you had
eight shows a week to hone
probably the one I just did
um I mean it's always the one I just did
but but kind of for good reasons not
filled with regret just that I felt so
um I don't know alive kind of like
eating a hot sauce really that's what it
does blew my mind it does yeah gets the
blood pumping gets the heart racing and
on the topic are you ready to move on
here to Sauce number six okay
thank you Scotch that's very good for
your gut turmeric nobody's got better
digestion than me no
that's the Scotch bonnet kind of a
deeper burn here
which was a bigger challenge for you in
your preparation for your Oscar
award-winning performance is Catherine
Hepburn and The Aviator was it learning
to play tennis or taking cold showers
tennis was actually tennis was a
homecoming because I used to play a lot
of tennis when I was a girl and we were
filming in Montreal so we had we joined
the oldest tennis club now it's starting
to get hot yeah yeah the oldest
[Music]
tennis club in Montreal and you had to
wear all whites
so it was it that it's a pressure when
you're playing in a club because
everyone takes it really seriously it's
a bit like golf
do you play golf no no there's one thing
it's like I don't understand leaf
blowers and I don't understand golf
well now I'm interested would you not
like a place to to another only for them
to be
like the gardeners I mean their faces
they know that what they're doing is
stupid right it's really it's bad
oh it's when you you can't breathe it I
know we're at that point in the show
[Music]
comma sauce that's a great name it is
[Music]
taking smaller and smaller bites that's
how it goes that's how it goes on this
show that's sweet too yeah but then it
kind of Builds on you a little bit
you see I've just been pushing them all
over the corner of my mouth
do you have a favorite one of your
scenes or most memorable Kate Blanchett
scene revolving around food oh I had
I had um I had to cook
um I had to to prepare a meal in a Barry
Levinson film that about two and a half
people saw
called Bandits
and um that so that that was more about
the the preparation process and it was a
it was a dance number so it's more about
that I love that I love that I'm now my
eyes are watering I know I know but just
be careful be careful no but that's an
amazing trick actually an actor told me
an older actor stage actor told me you
know you need to cry you turn up stage
and pull a nostril hair
and it works but but now I know is as
you turn upstairs you've got a little
bit of hot sauce on your finger and then
yeah you can play Greek tragedy one more
food question for you okay can I sure
yep
very careful I know yeah yeah
the original Tim Tam girl fall on your
list of career accomplishments and then
do you have a favorite line from one of
those 90s commercials yeah I know I I am
I wanted to go to to India
and I didn't have any money and then I
got a Tim Tam commercial which is pretty
much up there because it's one of my
all-time favorite biscuits but I mean
talking about having to eat the same
thing over and over that's the thing
with
with doing something like that is I had
a lot of tim tams and then
I never ate them ever again
because you do eat a lot of them when
you you know I guess it's like if you
did a car commercial right like yeah in
a show or you eat wings all the time
would you imagine
it is what it says in the bottle I guess
Beyond insanity all right
it hasn't kicked in yet maybe it won't
maybe it's like it hurts when you talk
and eat at the same time right it's like
your parents always say don't talk and
eat at the same time there's a reason
for that yeah
so with Halloween right around the
corner I think it's a good time to lean
into your affection for the horror genre
once sane yes I love being terrified it
used to be a badge of honor if you could
sit through Halloween too up the top of
your head without thinking about it too
much what is like your scariest
quintessential movie that you have to
watch during Halloween
I I think
it'd have to be something by Sam right
you don't have to be able to
the thing that makes me scream in magic
tricks like if you were to do a pull a
card out of a lemon right now or
anything like that or make an airplane
disappear which one musician I'm a
magician told me the other day that he
could do I mean they always talk big
right right but um yeah I made a Lear
jet disappear I was like oh did you I'm
so I'm so gullible magic tricks that's
what makes me scream
I think one of the one of the scariest
movies I've ever seen is the is the
original version of the Ring it we had
we got so scared we're in the house by
ourselves we've got so scared back in
the day BHS that we had we had to we
started we turned the sound down
and then we had we watched it fast
forwarded and we were still shooting our
pants
but that's how scary it was but there
was you know no blood I don't actually
know what the film was about but it was
terrifying
[Music]
okay unique garlic
oh I'm gonna eat it okay all right
so when we had Seth Meyers on the show
he likened documentary now to building a
ship in a bottle a hobby that lets him
escape from his everyday work grind what
to you was the appeal of that show when
you appeared in a parody of a
performance artist Loosely based on
Marina Abramovich well I I they asked me
to to do that one and it's always great
to excuse me sorry Mom
um you should never belch in public
um
um and and that was such a strange ask
you know so but but the one I pitched to
them was then they um I had a they said
look if you ever see a documentary that
you think is right for kind of um
parodying let us know and I saw this
really sweet documentary set in
Blackpool in the north of England about
uh three different hairdressing salons
and up in the north of England all they
talk about is dying it's just like death
is just you know we sit down and we
would have talked about how whoever you
know that that's all we would discuss
and um it was such a sweet beautiful
documentation I gave it to them and they
went for it I mean we could probably
though how would we parody this oh we
can make it have you made it if you look
make it documentary about yourself then
I'll send it to Seth and then I can play
you
whoa you know that's a meta idea isn't
it I love that yeah
that's a crowd pleaser that's gonna work
okay what's this this looks really are
you gonna throw it at me or something is
that what this is for oh do we have to
pour this on
[Music]
oh now you're just showing off I didn't
want to do that I didn't mean to do that
all right
so this is the moment where I could
actually
throw up no it's uh it's the moment that
will forever live in glory okay Cheers
Cheers Cheers big ears
[Music]
I know really not good
we've reached the end and just one more
question before we can roll credits and
I've heard you talk about the memories
that you have of doing musical at
University that would play to a crowd of
three two of whom left at intermission
but even after all the success the
international franchises the countless
Awards and Fanfare you still to this day
say the only way I can do it is I just
pretend that no one's going to see it
how is having a no one's going to see it
philosophy served you as an actor
well it it was a it was a um it was a
very memorable experience we met I mean
we did a we did a musical about climate
change and I realized then that you know
you should probably
um not have that crossover too often and
we did have three people in the audience
and after the intermission there was one
little old lady and um we said we said
there were seven of us in the show and
we said you know she didn't have to stay
there but she um
she really wanted us you know to play it
out so we did but I think it's just it's
the way I deal with the anxiety of it
because you have to have you have to
have a sense of a lack of consequence
you know what I mean so if you're gonna
embarrass yourself and acting is
embarrassing a lot of time you embarrass
yourself in public you know you really
do have to pretend that no one's going
to see it and frankly that's often the
case with the things I do
but hopefully not with time
not with tar and I don't think with this
episode either throwing caution to the
wind taking on the hot ones Gauntlet and
living to tell the tale and now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life
what what like if you have a movie
coming out or anything oh
field
is this is this can I do this yeah can I
tell people go ahead I'm not going to
tell you anything except that you have
to go and see tar Todd fields
film
about a conductor who I play a conductor
a major Symphony Orchestra
whose past catches up with her it's not
a horror movie but she man she is
haunted by a lot of ghosts
and you have to it's a the sound is
incredible he'll go to dotier who did
the score for Jokers done the
composition that I played it's amazing
Nina the great Nina Hoss one of the
great actresses I'm you know we
um play um husband and wife
and it's it's amazing
you did so good you did so good
that's really hot
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
fans thank you so much for watching
today's video If you want to get your
hands on the season 19 hot Ones hot
sauce Gauntlet boy do I have good news
for you just visit heatness.com
heatness.com that's heatness.com to get
your hands on the 10 pack the season 19
hot ones 10 pack hot ones in a box
delivered right to your door I highly
recommend it it's delicious I eat it
every week
[Music]